since disneyland first opened in anaheim
california in 1955 the park has hosted
hundreds of millions of visitors many
leave with souvenirs of their experience
but one devoted fan went a lot further
amassing one of the largest collections
of disney park memorabilia ever
assembled and now it's headed for the
auction block omar villafranca has the
story
there's a feeling that i get every time
i go to disneyland and walk through the
gates and see that train come into the
station
then walk through the tunnel
and there's main street
and i'm getting goose bumps just
thinking about it southern california
resident scott rummel has an obvious
love for everything disney and a special
connection to disneyland he's a
professional voice over artist and back
in the 90s he could be heard every day
on the park's pa system ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls
in just five minutes
fantasy in the sky fireworks at
disneyland
rumble's devotion to disney was so great
that over the years he decided to bring
parts of the park home with him piece by
piece your house was basically a disney
museum
it really was people would walk in and
say oh my goodness this is amazing we
called it the second happiest place on
earth
rumble's collection grew to a whopping
45 000 items from disneyland and other
disney parks around the world
acquired from auctions garage sales and
even former disney employees it includes
everything from cast member name tags to
big ticket items like vehicles from
iconic rides so this is a mr toad car
from walt disney world and they were
rotting away in the florida sun and rain
how many tens of thousands of people
have probably ridden in this car
millions millions disneyland has been a
part of rummel's life since he was a boy
growing up just a few miles away
when he married in 1982 he found a
kindred spirit in his wife terry she had
probably 20
donald duck items
and she really liked that and i thought
you know that would be a fun thing to do
together why don't we collect not just
donald duck but disney i started out by
anything that had the disney name on it
lunch boxes little figurines whatever
just like at the park all rides must
come to an end the couple wants to
downsize their life and move to a beach
house that means it's time to sell what
experts call one of the most
comprehensive collections of disney
memorabilia that will ever come to
market the flaws in these
actually are what bring them value
joshua benish is a disney expert at
heritage auctions which is conducting
the sale later this month what makes the
park stuff so different than say a
poster you know there's something
tangible about it there's something real
world about it there's something
visceral about all of these things
they're things that were part of your
disneyland experience you're really
selling a tangible memory
you're selling a piece of magic
and that's something that's hard to put
a price on just got to keep your hands
and arms inside the vehicle at all times
some of the other items going up for bid
a gondola that was used at disneyland
and disney world's now defunct skyway
for a lot of people this was you're high
up above the park you get to see
everything this was what my wife asked
like your wife wanted this no what do
you want
where are we going to put this gondola
you know
a bell that walt disney himself used to
ring part of the rainbow caverns mine
train pulls into the station you'd hear
this
your smile just got bigger you're a kid
again yeah i'm a kid again and a car
from the autopia ride the first car
rumble ever drove now he just hopes his
collection of a lifetime will find a way
to thrill disney fans for years to come
i obviously went a little bit crazy with
45 000 items i get that and people are
but i feel like there are so many cool
pieces that i just hope that the
collection continues to bring joy to
people for cbs saturday morning omar
villafranca dallas
there is so much to collect i have tons
of disney memorabilia myself having
grown up just outside the park maybe not
just outside but love everything disney
been going to disney world since i was
like three when i ran up to donald duck
and hugged him and ran back to my
parents and proclaimed i hugged the
chicken i hugged the chicken
i've learned since then